i'm definitely roll doll tied so you're
an anti-semite
yikes
honestly i just want to let you know if
you've ever like dm'd me or left a
comment that starts with yikes or ends
with yikes like you will be black
includes yikes in the middle because
people who say yikes on the internet in
like an ironic derogatory ironic way
like yeah we say it like making fun of
those people but the people who use it
in their everyday karen energy are the
worst people on the internet i literally
like screenshotted a message the other
day it was so [__] condescending like
yikes it was about the couch he was like
chill the [__] out
yikes you guys have lost your touch that
couch i'm like you're [__] ugly okay
i want to see your couch yeah facetime
me
yikes
i hate the word yikes so much
me too yes
and it comes with that face you know
yikes
[Laughter]
if you've ever said that like you're
done